This is Jocko podcast number
three with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
So last show we dug into the book
about face by Colonel David Hackworth
and today we're gonna dive into aid.
Another book on that was very influential
to me and it's called the last hundred
yards.
Now this book is very different from
about face in many ways. Number one,
it's,
it was not a New York Times bestseller.
It was probably never on any
kind of list of any kind.
It's a legit tactical guidebook
for people in the military.
That's what it is.
And I'm going to tell you a little
bit about the author right now.
Guy named Hj Poole who retired from
the Marine Corps in 1993 when he was on
active duty. He studied small
unit tactics for nine years,
six months at the basic
school in quantum of Quantico,
seven months as a platoon
commander in Vietnam,
three months as a rifle company commander
at Camp Pendleton in 1967 five months
as a regimental headquarters company
commander in Vietnam in 1968 eight months
as a rifle company commander in Vietnam,
1968 to 1969 five and a half years as
an instructor with advanced infantry
training
down at Camp Camp Lajune.
While he was at that advanced infantry
training company, he developed,
taught refined courses of instruction
on maneuver warfare, land navigation,
fire support coordination,
call for fire, adjust fire,
close air support two oh three grenade
launcher movement to contact daylight
attack, night attack,
infiltration, defense offense,
Iv military operations in urban terrain,
defensive military
operations in urban terrain,
NBC defense and leadership.
So the guy has some good background and
this book was very influential to me
when I was coming up.
And again,
as I just like with about face as I was
thinking about what I was going to say
about it and I wanted to talk about when
I got it and I couldn't remember when I
got about face.
It just Kinda came into my life at some
point and it's the same thing with the
last hundred yards and I don't really
know 100% when I got it or who told me to
get it.
It's one of those things that just
became so ingrained with me that now I,
I didn't want to even
remember when it happened. So
one of the,
one of the key kind of components or,
or the basis of the book that I kind
of have to introduce you to is it,
it talks about something called maneuver
warfare and maneuver warfare is a,
is a obviously a type of warfare.
It's a type of technique and it's,
it's counter to something
that's called attrition warfare.
Now you could probably guess
what attrition warfare is.
Attrition warfare is we're
going to go against the enemy,
we're going to go stand toe to toe and
we're going to punch each other in the
face until one of us goes down.
Now when you add bombs and
bullets into that scenario,
it means we're going to stand across
from each other, from the enemy,
and we're going to shoot each other and
bomb each other until one of us breaks.
And that's very American way of fighting
is to start this attrition warfare
because why? We've got massive
supplies, we've got awesome industry,
and we can get away with that.
Maneuver warfare is,
is very different,
and to go into the book a little bit
in talking about maneuver warfare,
this is what maneuver warfare is.
In maneuver warfare,
the emphasis is on maneuver.
Firepower is considered important
only to the extent that it facilitates
maneuver.
The overall offensive mission is to
win decisively by getting the enemy to
surrender.
So it's very different
you in in that definition,
they're not even looking to
kill the person, the enemy,
they're looking to make them surrender
because it's in some ways easier.
If the enemy surrenders, you
don't have to kill them all. Now
to go on the focus is outward
on the enemy. Again, this is,
this is maneuver warfare.
The focus is outward on the enemy
and a few mistakes like outdistancing
ones logistical support or shooting in a
friendly unit are
acceptable and unavoidable.
So that's kind of crazy,
right? That you actually,
you take these risks in maneuver warfare
where you might engage friendly forces.
You might get so separated that
you end up in a bad situation,
but it's because you're pushing the pace.
Control is decentralized and every sub
unit or individual is encouraged to
display the initiative needed to react
successfully to the local threat.
And this is the biggest
distinguisher between attrition warfare
and the way it's run and maneuver
warfare.
Decentralized Command.
And that is a chapter in the book
extreme ownership that Leif and I wrote.
It's,
that's one of the laws of combat that we
talk about is decentralized command is
that everybody that's
out on the battlefield,
every individual unit leader can make
decisions on their own and they can make
something happen.
They can react and they can execute
without having to run it up the chain of
command. That's maneuver warfare
very, very different. And,
and you know these days where we
see the big difference, you know,
you see a big bureaucratic company,
you know now that we're
working with businesses,
we see a big bureaucratic company,
they become very centralized in their
control and they fight attrition warfare
against other companies because they're
bigger and they have more resources.
Whereas you see the young startups,
what are they doing?
They're doing maneuver warfare there.
They've got decentralized command,
they've got people taking chances,
they're taking risks and they've got
different leaders out there on the
battlefield that are trying
to make things happen.
The emphasis is on training personnel
and this is back to the book.
The emphasis is on training personnel,
well enough ahead of time that they
can follow their commander's intent in
combat after only receiving
broad guidance. Of course,
sub unit must still keep their commanders
informed of any actions that might
affect adjacent units.
So you end up with a situation where
the commander is not telling
you exactly what to do.
They giving you broad
guidance, hey, this is the,
this is the end state of the mission
that I want to have accomplished.
And they're not telling you
exactly how to accomplish it.
They're just telling you what they
want done. So that's, uh, that's,
that's a difference between the two.
Now
there's a piece that's
very different as well,
or
maybe not different,
but another key element of maneuver
warfare and decentralized command versus
attrition warfare and centralized
command. So if you don't, if,
if you're listening and you haven't
been in the military before,
the military is separated
into two groups of people,
officers ended listed people.
The officers are sort of
the senior leaders who are,
you know, strategic planners and they're,
they're, they're the broader, higher up,
higher ranking leaders.
And then the enlisted are the tacticians,
the folks that are shooting the
machine guns, throwing their grenades,
making things happen. And
they do have, you know, the,
the enlisted service men also have
their noncommissioned officers,
which are the senior
ranking enlisted guys,
which are usually the expert
tacticians but it's interesting.
So this is going back to the book
now in in the average platoon,
the NCO pose provide most of the
collective experience. So again,
you see this sometimes in the movies
where they get the young officer and
they're green and they don't
really know what's going on.
And then you get the salty old,
you know,
bad ass that's played by a
salty old, you know, uh, uh,
Clint Eastwood and easily that
older guy with all the experience.
And that's what that saying this,
the ncls provide most of the
collective experience. For this reason,
they should participate in
most of the tactical decisions.
That absolutely makes sense.
This should have no way challenged
the authority of the officer's. Okay,
that's that sensible.
After all commissioned and
noncommissioned officers share the same
responsibilities in combat.
If the lieutenant, which
is the officer is wounded,
the platoon sergeant takes over
when they both, this is key.
When they both work together,
better decisions, result,
obviously you've got two
mines and instead of one,
this brain trust can be further
enhanced by including squad leaders.
So they're, they're saying,
let's bring in more minds,
more of these junior enlisted guys.
Let's find out what they think.
The enduring satisfaction that
comes from making the situation,
the correct decision,
and then having that decision
fully supported during
execution far outweighs the
temporary insecurity that may come
from soliciting the advice of support
minutes. I love that quote. I love
that because I'm going to say it again.
So it's saying that the decision and the
execution doing that well far outweighs
the temporary insecurity that may
come from soliciting the advice of
subordinates.
So,
and I used to see this with
these young junior officers,
if they're insecure with their leadership,
they don't want to take advice and they
definitely don't want to ask for advice
because they feel like that makes them
look weak or they don't know what they're
talking about. They don't know
what they're talking about. Oh,
they're going to lose respect.
That's all their ego talking
and is their insecurity talking.
Whereas you get a young officer
that's smart and that's confident.
He has no problem looking at the gunnery
sergeant or looking at the platoon
chief and saying, hey chief, how do
you think we should do this? Hey chief,
I've never even seen this
type of operation before.
Can you give me some help or can let,
can you take lead on this?
And that is the way a
real leader operates.
You don't always see that, unfortunately.
Same thing with the mistakes too, right?
When you say, Oh man, I made
that mistake. Oh, exactly.
It's hard to do that a lot of
the time because they think, oh,
this guy doesn't know what he's doing.
Obviously made a mistake even
admitted it kind of thing. Yeah,
and w w what the reality is, people don't
actually think that. They don't think,
oh, he just admitted his mistake. He
really doesn't know what he's doing. No,
they go, okay, well at least
he's aware of his mistake.
Unless everything they do as a mistake,
then that's different.
But on the other hand,
it is courting disaster to rely on one's
personal impressions to provide the
solution to complex scenario and then not
consider whether one subordinates have
the skills to execute that solution.
So don't sit there
stuck in your own brain,
afraid to ask anybody else
or you're going to lose.
Now
as we push through this,
we can get pretty deep,
um,
to you is going back to the book again,
t to a US infantry men actively
engaged in a losing effort.
This shortage of rest reference material
can be quite unsettling. And what this,
what this is talking about previously
to this sentence is saying that although
there's all kinds of books
and manuals in the military,
this detailed reference material of
exactly how to do the front line,
what is that point man do?
What does that machine gun or do?
How do they actually do it?
That information can get lost cause it's
more past word of mouth than anything
else.
Okay?
And it goes into a talking about,
believe it or not, Hackworth,
with a combat commission from Korea,
Lieutenant Colonel David Hackworth was
no stranger to war. When he called,
when he was called to serve
in Vietnam after two tours,
he pointed out that the u s knowledge
on Small Unit infantry tactics had not
been significantly enhanced by the longest
war in us history, meaning Vietnam.
And here's what,
here's what Hackworth said,
almost 15 years since the tragic
inevitable fall of Saigon.
And this is so he's saying this 15
years after the end, the Vietnam war,
almost 15 years since the end, since
the tragic inevitable fall of Saigon,
there's been no major,
honest, postmortem of the war.
There have been critiqued
dealing with the big picture,
but none has addressed the lessons
learned the hard way at the fighting level
where people died and
the war was in fact lost.
So all those lessons learned in all those,
no one ever made an honest critique and
dug down onto the battlefield to see
what these guys could do. And I know
I talked about this last time as well,
is that when I first
got in the seal teams,
there was guys from Vietnam
and when those guys spoke,
you absolutely listened because
you were hearing knowledge,
knowledge and
that
if I didn't experience that, if I didn't
meet those guys, I will no one, you know,
I wouldn't hurt it.
It wasn't written down anywhere.
And so you've got to always
remember when you do learn stuff,
you got to write it down. And you
know, Lafe and I talk about that,
the fact that when we got
back from Ramadi, you know,
I started teaching it trade at
what's called training detachment.
And he started teaching the, the
seals that were coming out of, uh,
the new guys that were coming out of the
seal training. And that's where we were,
had the opportunity to really capture a
lot of this information that we learned
in Ramadi and we were able to pass it on.
And ultimately those lessons
learned or what became the book.
Okay.
So that being said,
you start talking about doctrine.
And I can tell you that doctrine
is not everything. In fact,
and you'll hear me talk about people,
People's biggest strengths are
often their biggest weaknesses.
So if you have someone that's
super aggressive and they're,
they're aggressive in the business
world or making things happen,
and that's a real advantage for them,
but they can get over aggressive and
then they end up doing stupid things and
they fail.
Right?
That's one example of how your biggest
strength can be your biggest weaknesses
in the seal teams,
we really didn't have,
we had very limited doctrine and it was
a real big weakness for us because if
you had never run a certain
type of operation before,
you couldn't refer back to something
and say, okay, here's the method or the,
the written documentation of how
you're supposed to do it. So that's,
that's pretty weak. That's pretty
horrible. That's a big weakness.
But at the same time,
it was a strength because
as the battlefield changes,
we started getting tasked with missions
that we had never done before that no
one had ever done before.
We were very adaptable because we were
used to trying to figure things out so
it's a strength and weakness.
That being said,
and although we did capture
much of our lessons learned,
this is going back to the book here,
basic field manual talking about all
these manuals that capture the doctrine.
Knowledge is fine but it is
useless without common sense.
Common sense is of greater value than
all the words in the book and this is
another thing they will stereotypically
put in Hollywood movies about cops are
about soldiers. You know you've got some
guy that's buy the book, buy the book,
buy the book in and you can see
this is calling it out. This is,
this is colonel armor,
our sims or guy that was in the Marine
Corps on Guadalcanal and he said that
common sense was more important than
anything in the in the field manuals,
which is something I completely agree with
and to carry that point a
little bit further back to
the book and here's a quote
from major general fuller.
The central ideas of an army
is known as its doctrine,
which to be sound must be
based on principles of war
and which to be effective
must be elastic enough to admit of
mutation in accordance with change in
circumstance.
So again,
these all these people
that really understand war,
they know that this doctrine is
something that needs to be written.
It needs to exist,
but it needs to be adapted to and common
sense is is the superior rank over
doctrine. In another thing, and this is,
this is a
a
a comment on training because it becomes
very difficult when you think about
training people for
situations that are unknown.
It's easy to train something people for
something that they know is going to
happen,
but it's a lot more difficult to train
people for something that is unknown.
How do you do that?
As we get into the discussion
of training a little bit,
the small unit into the book here,
the small unit that to faithfully
follows the method in the book,
we'll eventually attempted under
the wrong conditions. Furthermore,
the unit may have a diff,
have difficulty,
surprising any enemy who has read
their book. That makes sense,
right? The enemy's going to
know your play. And by the way,
all these military manuals
can all be found online.
They're online,
they're on the Internet.
So the enemy definitely reads
what we have. On the other hand,
the unit that doesn't prepare
for any particular scenario,
we'll take too long to decide what to do
automatically sacrificing surprise and
momentum and then not have the teamwork
to execute what it does decide to do.
So there's two ends of the spectrum.
You know,
we talk about the dichotomy of leadership
and how you're constantly going
against opposing forces.
Well, here's, you know,
you can train so hard and so specifically
to what to doctrine that it eliminates
your flexibility.
The other end of the spectrum is to not
train at all and then you can't execute
anything.
And Rommel,
Rommel said,
the ordinary soldier has a surprisingly
good nose for what is true and what is
false and an eye that's not just soldiers.
You know what?
I talked about that before,
that people know,
even if they don't know what the truth is,
they know you're not telling them that
he might not know what the actual truth
is.
And,
and then going back to
training in actuality at back
to training and back to the
book and actuality motes most small
scale combat is won or lost months before
the battle during training.
And that's something that people say
all the time about mixed martial arts as
well. You know, it's during
that training as you prepare,
that's what wins the battle. It's a fight
camp, right? It's the same thing with, uh,
with military maneuvers.
So as we continue on here,
as expected,
battlefield conditions change.
So too must learning
overreliance on books.
Solutions in itself constitute a short
fall in training because it minimizes the
importance of the unique
aspects of each situation.
Blind faith in standard
operating procedures doesn't
even constitute being well
trained. This is something
that when I was training,
we caused complete mayhem on the guys
that were going through training and
anybody that went through training when
I was running it right now as a smile on
their face because they know that
they were put into scenarios that were
completely confusing,
distracting,
disturbing, mayhem, chaos.
It was just crazy.
And the reason we did that is because
we wanted to test their minds,
not their standard operating procedures,
not uh,
their shooting capabilities. We wanted
to test the minds of the leaders.
Could the leaders be in that chaos,
stepped back from that chaos,
either physically or mentally or both
get an assessment of everything that was
happening and then say,
okay,
this is what we need to do to get out of
the situation or improve the situation
or when the situation,
what the other thing that it requires,
not only is that the leaders step
back and have the ability to set back,
but the NCO is again,
these noncommissioned officers must love
initiative and must hold what ground
they have to the utmost.
It often happens that a sergeant or even
a corporal corporal made aside a battle
by boldness with which he sees
as a bit of ground and holds it.
So we tried to inspire the younger guys,
the new guys,
a guy that had no experience in the seal
teams, but we wanted that guy to go,
you know what, I'm going to get in this
room or I'm going to take this building,
I'm going to get to this rooftop,
I'm going to get this good position.
And not to do it
as a rogue element,
but within the confines of what the
strategy was and what the plan was.
And that's where you end up with an,
with a unit that works together very well.
And uh,
you know,
one of the things that I remember of
where people get locked into these,
you can see it sometimes in MMA fights.
You'll see a fighter that's got a good,
you know,
ground game or he's,
and all he's trying to do is take the
person down and take the person down using
all their energy.
Just keeps trying to clench,
keep keeps shooting shots and
they're getting their shots stuff,
but they can't adapt.
They don't have the skills or they
don't have the mindset to adapt.
I remember one scenario where
we had what's called a bunkered machine
gun position. This isn't a training,
a training event. So there's a long
hallway. This is in an urban environment.
There's a big giant building.
This is all fake by the way,
but there's a big giant building and in
the end of the hallway we've got a bad
guy who's in a bunkered position.
So he's in behind tables and drawers and
concrete and he's got a fully automatic
paintball gun and the seals are trying
to go down the hallway to get them and
they're shooting at him.
But this guy isn't a bunkered position.
They can't hit him.
He's hidden.
And so every time they come out in the
hallway to try and move towards him,
he just mowed them down. And first
is one guy, then it's another guy,
then three guys,
then it's six guys that it's eight guys
are laying in the hallway, you know,
cause every time they
get shot with paint ball,
if they get shot a few times we're
putting them down like, okay, you're dead.
Just lay down, stay there, you're dead.
Stay there, you're dead. Okay you're you,
you're dead to, they can't move.
They just got to lay there.
So I go to the guy that's running it
and it was a platoon chief and I walked
over and I said, hey chief, you know,
how's this going to work out? And he said,
we just got to, I've got to get these
guys moving down this hallway. And I said,
do you think there might be another way?
And he kind of looked at me
and he realized that, yeah,
there's another way. He sent a
couple guys back out of the building.
They walked the down the outside of the
building to the window where the guy was
bunkered in through a couple of grenades
in there, jumped in, killed the guy.
But the mindset wasn't there to
have the flexibility to do that.
And that's what we are training.
Cause I never wanted to see guys
get locked in to a situation.
That's why training all training
needs to expand your brain.
They need to expand your mind
needs to it shouldn't constraint,
shouldn't constrain your ideas.
Yeah.
It almost seems like that would
be a different type of training.
Even almost like you could like phone with
fourth of the double leg or something.
They're forcing, they're not
getting it. They're not getting it.
He should have been trained
in other take downs.
If in fact taking the guy
down was the strategy.
You should be trained in other stuff.
They'll be some judo stuff. No,
no doubt about it.
And this is one,
one thing that's interesting and I th
I think that's the e the evolution is
you're hearing,
you know about Conor McGregor right now,
and I hate to jump on the bandwagon,
but you know you see him doing
like this movement type drills,
which is really good because what does
that doing that's training you for these
weird situations? You know?
And that's another issue.
Like with training
Jujitsu with Jeff Glover.
He puts himself in these weird positions
and does these crazy things that when
it happens to him,
he just has better reaction because
he's used to being in these strange
positions. And when we
work with corporations, um,
and work with companies,
we'll,
we'll do role playing with these CEOs
are mid level managers and we'll,
we'll play, you know, Lafe and
I will play the unruly old,
you know,
uh,
job site foreman that knows more than
you do and how are you going to deal with
them?
And we put them in these
hostile situations and do
things and say things and
that, that throw them for a loop
that make them uncomfortable, that,
that they don't know
the solution to and they
have to think on their feet. And
that's, that's one of the, you know,
one of the pieces of training
that I always like to go
back to you is how can we,
how can we do things that surprise
people in training so that,
so that we exercise their brain,
not now what they know. We don't,
we got to get what you know,
you gotta train, which you know,
you got to practice what, you know,
how do we train what you don't know,
which you don't expect.
Yeah. It's like a deeper,
it's like almost like a
level deeper in the training.
Like it's like,
it's real beneficial I think.
I think Henry guys talk
about this training. Jujitsu,
a good way to train for self defense is
trained with a real athletic guy who's a
white belt so he won't do
predictable things that you've
been training every day.
He'll do unpredictable things
where you won't be super easy.
Um,
and at the same time it won't be something
that you have full knowledge of and
full experience of it.
If you get the 280 pound powerhouse
that shows up to the gym that's never
trained before,
the first time you train with them,
it's going to be harder
to catch him then it will
three months later. Now, maybe, maybe
three months, it'll be about the same.
But like a month into it where he kind of
knows what he's supposed to try and do.
Right. But you know exactly what he's
going to do, then it's easy to catch him.
It's easier. So you're, you're
right, it definitely is a,
is a transitional time and it is good to
train with people that you have no idea
what they're going to do. Yeah. And it's
not even to say that, that, and it does,
it gives you experience with
these unorthodox things for sure.
But that's not what you're talking
about as far as what's being trained,
what's being trained is not
to be so dogmatic in your
actions and your, you know,
your, your plan is to this,
this sounds really cliche.
It's to expect the unexpected. Right.
But it trains you to think that way.
Well, it's true. And I don't
know if this is cliche or not.
I'm pretty sure it is,
but I say this and people kind of freak
out when I say it because I'm like, uh,
a structured, disciplined person. But
I say it all the time. Free your mind.
You know, you got to free your mind.
That's why when I talk about this stuff,
I hate when I find myself in a situation
where my mind is not free to see what's
going on and I can't detach
from what's known. Yeah. And,
and go and enter the unknown and,
and, and deal with the unknown. Yeah.
You know,
another thing that can affect this is
our ego and how our ego can prevent
us from learning or listening to other
people or other schools or other
martial arts or other gyms or other
perspectives. So it, in this book,
the last hundred yards,
he talks about that,
uh,
even giving
a sister organization
with the same manuals,
credit for knowing
anything can be difficult.
Pride in one's unit can
help to build cohesion,
but it can also stand
in the way of learning.
Learning must always take
priority over pride. How readily,
how readily a military organization
can assimilate new information,
establishes how easily it's component
elements can acquire new knowledge.
The Germans of World War One are
generally credited with developing the
application parameters that
define modern infantry tactics.
Here's how they did it.
The German army of 1914 was the
most decentralized in Europe,
free from all book,
the most general supervision and relieved
by a promotion system that based based
strictly on seniority of the need
to constantly please superiors.
The German battalion or company commander
was free to train his troops according
to his own lights.
So they way they advanced people is just
how it wasn't based on how well you did
on this particular thing. So they
weren't kissing ass the whole time.
It was just oh you and rank you,
now you get promoted.
So they were free to kind of operate and
do the best they could and that had a
big,
big impact
for,
for example,
by 1918 the Germans had line infantry
squads that could penetrate ally defense
lines almost at will as opposed to,
you know,
the,
the allies who would always try and
coordinate these big giant massive attacks
at the same time.
And you have to get everyone aligned
and you have to execute perfectly with
thousands of people. That's obviously
very challenging. Rather than just saying,
okay, our goal is to break through
the lines, go and figure it out.
Think of all the different creative ways
that go to figure that out. And it's,
it's crazy and that's why it was so
successful. Now the Germans lost,
they obviously made some
mistakes on those strategic level
and as a matter of national policy,
they made some pretty big mistakes too.
But that's kind of a, that's kind of
a whole nother, a whole nother story.
Most military leaders agree that doing
nothing to prepare an infantry squad for
combat also does little to
enhance its chances for success.
Most can also agree that providing
guidance that is too restrictive may cause
the squad to disregard
unforeseen circumstances.
The answer to that must
lie somewhere in between.
That's what we've been talking about.
And you see this with fighters as well,
and you see fighters that prepare
for a specific attack from somebody,
but then that other,
somebody decides to mix it up and
comes out and does something that's,
it's happen to me when I was cornering
fighters before where I've gone out and
said, oh, I didn't expect that. Here
we go. This guy just took, you know,
Jon bones just took down a DC,
you know, like, where'd that come?
Why did he do
that? So we see that kind of, that,
that mentality that throws things off and
it puts people in a, in a predicament.
Yeah. And you mentioned
John Jones. He, um,
he actually even admitted that some
of the stuff that he does, he just,
he's never trained for, he just did it.
Yeah. But it's, man, it's that different,
that separate element of your
mind or that are training,
I don't know if you had training doing
that are just a creative person or
whatever. Um, just that separate element.
It's a whole different part of this
strategy, you know? Yeah. On other asset.
Yeah. And also you can see that
he's encouraged by Greg Jackson.
He's encouraged and he does things, you
know, he, he has an open mind, right?
It's got a free mind and that
goes a long way for your mind.
That is kind of a cliche by the way.
There's a,
like a song isn't free of mine in the
rest of the flight hollow or something
else will fall out. In other words, I'm
not familiar with that. Let's not say.
Uh, so finally to talk about
decentralized command and,
and what I would see happen
with decentralized command
as I tell some junior
leader, okay, you know, you
need to decentralize command,
you'll need to let your guys go
out and do what they need to do.
And they go out on the
battlefield and this is, you know,
getting in training where
there no one's going to die.
They'd go out and all the little leaders
would get their own ID and they'd go
and try and make all the stuff that
happened and the commander would lose
control and everyone would get crushed in,
shot up with paint ball
and the whole nine yards.
And they come back and still utilize a
deduce which was community does work and
I would say no,
you did decentralized command but you
missed the key part of decentralized
command, which is guidance, parameters,
understanding of the mission,
Commander's intent,
standard operating procedures,
limits of advance,
all these nice little restrictions
that you put on the guys.
Now they're, they're wide restrictions.
I shouldn't have said little.
They're wide restrictions.
They give them a lot of mobility but
they understand what the objective is,
what the end state is, what their
parameters are, how far they can maneuver,
like they can know they can, hey,
if you can't go past this building,
you can't go past this road.
You can't go wherever you draw those
lines so that they can operate freely
within those lines and
that's how they're made.
That's how you maintain control
with decentralized command.
Would you call them like guidelines or,
cause when you say operate
within those lines,
is it pretty encouraged to stay within
those lines with their creativity or does
the creativity, is that allowed to
kind of overflow? Like if you say,
you know how far you can engage there,
are you saying that there are no
exceptions, no subjective, you know,
if I call you up and say Echo,
I'm a building 14 right now we see enemy
moving to building 27 I want to push
down this road. Are we good to
do that? And you say, all right,
let me check the map.
Let me check where I'm other forces
are at. Yep. Where you're good to go.
You can move.
So there are times where I have to check
back with you to make sure we're good
to go and make sure that you understand.
But I'm,
I'm going beyond what parameters were
set and that's why I have to communicate
to you.
But I went all the way up to that point.
I maneuvered on the battlefield for,
you know, three, four, five, six hours.
Maybe it was a day, maybe it was
two days without having to say Echo,
I need some guidance here. Echo, I'm going
to push beyond what you told me. Yeah.
So these guidelines are kind of,
you go in with the knowledge that
there are exceptions as long as they're
responsible.
Yes.
As long as what you do that you'd be
responsible about making those exceptions
and communicating.
I know that's when bad things happen.
When bad things happened
is when you go outside the,
the limitations that you're supposed
to be in and you don't tell anybody,
you know, that's a very,
very problematic now, um,
when we,
when we talk about why it's so why
you have to maintain that flexibility.
The reason is because combat is
infinitely complex and it's one of those
dichotomies because it's infinitely
simple, but it's infinitely complex.
And believe me,
the complexity of it got me,
got the best of me on many occasions
where I was, where I lost it. I did not,
could not fall the complexity situation.
I had two bad things happen.
I had to regroup.
I had to try and figure them out,
had to assemble these thoughts
in my head as all this thing.
All of these things are happening.
Go into the book as it relates to combat.
The term situation
encompasses many variables.
Mission, enemy, terrain,
weather troops and fire support,
time, space, logistics. Each
category has many facets.
Disregarding a seemingly inconsequential
sort put circumstance can invalidate an
otherwise logical solution.
One must continually
study the possibilities,
continually study the possibilities.
And I've seen that where one little
problem can escalate into all kinds of
problems. And that's something that
whether it's a unit that we dealt,
we did just what we just talked
about, which is, you know,
you get a unit that goes
where they weren't supposed
to be and they didn't tell
anybody. That can become very
problematic as you can imagine,
because all of a sudden,
you know,
you've got people shooting from a building
where there's not supposed to be any
friendlies. Well guess what? You're
going to shoot back at him, right?
So that's a horrible situation.
Things with communication where you know
some radio frequencies go down or for
whatever reason you lose communications
with people and all of a sudden you're
in a black hole and you
don't know what's happening.
That's another situation where one little
tiny piece can really throw massive
complexities into the situation.
Going back to Rommel and back to training.
Okay.
The best form of welfare for the
troops is first class training.
This saves unnecessary casualties.
And I think I did talk about this before,
but taking care of your people,
you know and how taking care
of your people, it can mean a,
that means we're were to cut them loose
early because that means you're taking
care of them.
But the reality is the way you take care
of them is to train them art that'd be
disciplined. So I'll, I'll, we'll
never lose sight of that one.
This is a skipping around a little bit,
but I wanted to throw
this in there because
because of the fight we had in Ramadi,
and it's just talking about how the
fighting and the urban environment is so
challenging and it says in
the book built up areas,
meaning cities should be bypassed
wherever possible. In urban terrain,
the attacker may need as much as
a 10 to one manpower advantage
and Sun Zoo who wrote the art of war,
the worst policy is to attack cities.
And if troops or attacking cities,
their strength will be exhausted.
That's just a for time immortal.
Trying to fight in cities is
absolutely the most challenging of all
environments. Why? Cause they're,
they're dug in and their, you know,
their little strategy kind of
is established. They're dug in.
They,
they are 360 degrees around you.
Oh yeah. They are above
you. They are to the left,
to the right in front of you. They're
behind you and they're beneath you.
They're in the sewage systems,
they're in the basements.
So you're in this 360 degree fire zone.
And on top of that,
just about every building is a
hardened fighting position. Yeah.
So, so all you have to do is enter a
building and you've got a pill box,
you've got a, you've got a bunker. And
so therefore it's very, very challenging.
And I just talked about having a enemy
machine gunner and a bunkered fighting
position.
That's a nightmare.
It's a little less of a nightmare when
you have tanks to come in and blast them.
Sure. So God blessed the
tankers. I love those guys.
We uh, worked side by
side with those guys. One,
one a d
guys crushed it for us
and we appreciated it.
Respect for one and one's enemy is
crucial to success on the battlefield.
He is not a coward, he is not stupid
and he probably has comparable weaponry.
That's from the book how to focus on
the enemy and make sure that you are,
you are respecting the enemy.
Flexibility to a changing situation.
Again in the book,
having the ability to detect and then
react to a changing situation can have
great value in war. What manuals contain
is mostly technique, not doctrine.
This technique is merely a framework
around which to build common sense
solutions and what that translates
to is discipline equals freedom.
You have these standard
operating procedures, you
work them, you refine them,
you practice them, you get good at
them but you don't get stuck with them.
You free your mind by having discipline
and it means that you can adapt these
strict standard operating procedures.
You can adapt them instantaneously and
do something else with them because
you're a maestro and you
can make that happen.
Now we get into this,
and this is going a little bit deep,
but we start talking about something
called mission type orders.
And that is different from let's say
what would be called a directive,
where I say, Echo, you're
going to move down this street.
You're going to take this building
number 27 you're going to set security in
there and you're going
to hold that position.
That's different because now I've told
you exactly what to do. I've said, okay,
echo,
you're gonna move down this street.
So I'm telling you which
way you're going to go.
I'm going to tell you exactly which
building you're gonna take down.
And I'm telling you just
to set security in there.
Now what I really want to say is that
that means you have to do what I just told
you because you have no choice. I mean,
I didn't give you any other options.
I told you exactly what to do.
Now what if I were to say Echo,
we think the enemies over in this area,
we want to be able to hold security
on them from an elevated position.
Find a building down there
and make that happen.
So now you've got all kinds of freedom.
You might pick 27 cause maybe it was
the best building, but maybe 36 wasn't,
maybe 32 was maybe 27 was hardened.
Maybe it wasn't tall enough.
But you have this organic flexibility
in your mind because you've been given a
goal of why you're doing the mission,
not just what to do.
So it's very important when
you're dealing with people,
you know in any walk of life that you
tell them not just what they're trying to
do, what to do, but what they're trying
to accomplish, what the mission is,
why they are doing it.
And that is incredibly important.
Just like aggressiveness is important.
And going back to the
book from General Howland,
Mad Smith,
since I joined the marines,
I have advocated aggressiveness in the
field and constant offensive action hit
quickly, hit hard and keep right
on hitting. Give the enemy no rest,
no opportunity to consolidate
as forces and hit back at you.
This is the shortest road to victory.
Do I need to even expand on that?
I mean,
I think how [inaudible] Mad Smith
just hit the nail on the head.
Next point,
controlling subordinates only to the
extent that surprised momentum are not
sacrificed.
Personnel should become so familiar with
their leader's intent that they can be
trusted to act on their own initiative.
They should never be required to ask
permission to respond to crisis situation.
Seconds count and close combat.
Subordinates must be trusted to act
appropriately and Rick only required to
inform the leaders of decisions
that might affect others. That's it.
That's decentralized command.
Now you're going to think at first
that this is a little bit of a stretch,
but it's not so controlling subordinates
only to the extent that surprise and
momentum are not sacrificed.
I'm going to relate that to Jujitsu.
Believe it or not,
in Jujitsu and in any sport,
you have to train your standard operating
procedures so that your body can
execute them without directives,
right?
If you have an instinct
to defend the arm lock,
you will escape the arm lock.
If you do not have that instinct
because you haven't trained it enough,
you will get caught in the arm lock.
If you have to think about the move,
it is too late. And that's exactly
what decentralized command is.
If echoes out on the battlefield and he
gets flanked and he has to ask me what
to do,
he's going to get killed.
If Echo's on the mat
with me and I slap a Kim,
you're on him and he has to think
about the defense. It's too late.
He's already tapping.
Whereas if I go for the Camaro and his
instinct moves him out of that position,
then you survive.
The, uh, one more thing that I,
when I think about that type of training
is something we used to do was called
blender drills.
When you take your seal squad or your
seal platoon and you start making calls on
them, plank left and you know, push
right strong, right center pool.
You just do the most random
calls. So that meeting calls, uh,
like you're making tactical
calls, you got, you got 16 guys,
they're called immediate action drills.
And for instance,
if you are patrolling through the desert
and you can start getting shot at from
the front, then you do a
what's called a contact drill.
You're going to react to that contact.
The contact is the enemy.
You're going to do a maneuver as a group
and they're all kind of choreographed
maneuvers where squad one goes over here,
a squad to goes over here.
We lay down a base of fire. You
start to move, cover and move out,
but what we would do is we would mix
up those calls in the middle of one
maneuver, we'd call for another
for it. In the middle of that one,
we'd call for another one in the middle
of that one we'd call for another one
and what it did was it trained the mind.
It trained the minds of the leaders and
if the guys to expect the unexpected,
as you said earlier in that cliched way,
but something that's completely necessary,
trained them to be reactive
and open minded to things
that were going to happen.
Now
when we talk about learning,
and this is a it,
the title of this chapter in,
in the book, the last hundred yards, it's
called old habits may get in the way.
Then I think it's pretty obvious what
that means. Adults learn. Here it is.
Adults learn within the context
of what they already know.
Ideas that are too far removed from their
personal frames of reference are hard
for them to accept. How often do
we see that? We see it in life.
We see it in the business world. We see
it in combat. We see it in training.
Ideas that are too far removed from
people's personal frame of reference are
hard for them to accept.
Unfortunately,
when one gets dropped into a hot
landing zone on his first day in combat,
it's often too late for him to
learn anymore. For this reason,
infantry must continually reassess
and expand their frames of reference.
Boom. Hello life. For this reason,
infantry men and everybody else in the
world must continually reassess and
expand their frames of reference.
Everybody when one survival's at stake
the other way can hold as much appeal as
the established way.
So clearly we see people in the business
world stuck in that Rut all the time.
We see people in their personal lives,
they get stuck in a Rut all the time.
So everybody has got to
continually reassess and expand,
expand their frame of reference.
Going back to the boat,
what adults know comes
primarily from two sources,
what they have been told and what they
have experienced personally. Okay.
That's pretty clear, right? I
think that's pretty obvious,
but this is when it gets pretty cool.
They sometimes have difficulty keeping
the 2 cents of ideas separated,
becoming convinced that what they have
been told is true even though they have
never personally experienced it.
And that is something that
you see in the military,
you see in the military
where guys kind of,
they hear something,
they make it into something that
they think that they've experienced.
I know it sounds crazy,
but they do it and
it's dangerous. It's
dangerous. And I never,
when I realized that that happened,
when I realized that that was going on,
I was very
suspect of everything that got said. Uh,
you know, I was very suspect and said,
well let's,
let's make sure that we confirm these
ideas before we just run out and do them.
Cause that kind of like
those, those martial arts
demonstrations. Right? Exactly,
exactly.
And you can imagine that before the
UFC and before you actually putting to
humans in a cage to brawl, it
was all theoretical. Right?
And if someone said, you know what, if
you strike the person here in the neck,
they will fall down. And, and this is the,
people legitimately believed that,
hey, if you hit the person in the neck,
there's a brachial nerve and it'll go
down to just go and stuff a are wrong and
they will immediately fall
down. And people believe
that. But they never tried it,
but they believed it.
And there was a lot of the times those
stories were mixed in with someone that
had been told that they'd seen it one
time or they experienced it or whatever.
And so that's a good
point. [inaudible] um,
and this is when you get into people
that are not telling the whole story.
And this is something I'm very careful
of is when I know something like no,
I never claim to know anything 100% and
now I will always caveat everything with
you know,
like a 99.9% but there's sometimes where
I'm giving information and I'm saying,
look, this is not 100% I
don't know this for sure,
but this is what I've seen and this is
what I've experienced. Sometimes I'm like,
hey listen,
I know this and I have experienced
it and this is what will work.
And I definitely,
when I was instructing in the seal teams,
I was very clear when I was saying,
Hey,
I have not done that type
of mission before or I have
not done this in combat or
I have not seen how
this would really work.
But here's what I think cause that's a
lot different than this is what you need
to do.
Because I have seen it,
I have done it and I do know confidently
that barring the common sense,
this is how you should execute this.
So sources back to the book,
sources have many reasons for not
disclosing every facet of an issue.
One is to propound more
convincingly their perspective.
Infantry men can't afford to harbor
points of view that aren't well founded.
They need continually to reassess their
viewpoint and expand their frames of
reference to encompass infantry knowledge
from around the world and across
centuries.
Awesome.
Free your mind does that kind of like,
I'm looking something up on
Google or on the Internet
and then the difference between just going
with that first answer and going with
the, you know, a bunch of,
a bunch of results. Bunch of
websites. Yeah. Right? Yeah.
And,
and people that see something on the
Internet and then talk about it as if they
know it firsthand.
Right.
When they read it on there for
that first result they got,
they clicked on and boom, there's your
answer. Yeah. Those people out there,
we don't like you.
You're clouding the truth.
Okay.
Getting into some leadership and really
life choices that you can apply these to
life. You can play as a business. Um,
here are some choices
that humans have to make.
Protect the status quo or take risks
necessary to win decisively that that's,
that speaks on its own.
Protecting the status quo can be easier
than changing it to take action. One,
risks making mistake.
So that's a choice and it's
not a black and white choice.
There's a lot of shades of gray in there.
And how can you modulate that choice?
But it is a choice that
you have to be aware of.
Focus inwards to prevent mistakes or on
the enemy to keep pace with a changing
situation.
This is an interesting professional.
Professionals of all types try to
minimize errors. Unfortunately,
trying to do,
trying too hard to do so in the military
profession has some serious tradeoffs
initiative,
ability to surprise one adversary
perspective on the overall picture and
learning just the name of true.
And I would say that those are the exact
same in any profession. That when you,
when you are only focused
on not making mistakes,
how are you going to make any risks
Jujitsu the minute that you're just like,
Hey,
I'm going to go with what I
know and I am so guilty of this.
I am the guiltiest of
all in that I'm very,
um, set in my ways in, in the
moves that I do. You know,
I do for submissions maybe even to,
you know,
uh, but you know, they're,
they're like what I'm good at.
So I do them a lot and I go through phases
and I shouldn't even say it's phases.
I go through days where I take a
lot of risks and I learned more.
And then I go through days where I'm just
there because I have to train and I'm
going to do what I do and I'm gonna
what I'm gonna do, what I do well.
But that's not what I learned.
That's not what I get better.
I get better when I'm
trying something new.
And that applies to everything in life.
Key to an infantry man's ability to
react to whatever confronts him is his
authority.
To exercise some initiative,
you got to give your people the
freedom to maneuver. You have to,
in combat,
the leader must personally supervise
only those actions that jeopardize the
overall mission and then
allow subordinates to
exercise initiative and make a
few mistakes on everything else.
Those subordinates must be
able to identify mistakes
as they happen without fear
of punishment or the same
mistakes will happen again.
This is making mistakes
without fear of punishment.
You know a dean are,
you know buddy dean lister,
he does these drills that
he calls consequence free
drills where he just says,
okay,
you're going to start.
You know that someone's going to be on
your back and you're going to try to
escape, but doesn't matter. It doesn't
matter what happens if they submit you.
It doesn't matter to just doesn't matter.
Consequence free drills.
It's just to take chances
because all of us, you know,
we all hate getting tapped out.
We all hate giving up position,
so you do these consequences. Regionals.
You Go, okay, I look at the guy in,
I'm like, okay, you're going to tap me
out. It's no big deal. You know, so do,
I'm going to try crazy stuff.
And that's what they're saying here.
You've got to give people
the chances to make mistakes
and that's an accident, an
important one because, um,
how that applies to life,
that applies to life.
Mm.
Right when you're born, when you're,
when you're a bit like if you,
let's say your parenting style,
if you have that parenting style
where I can make some mistake,
he spills his milky or
he's trying something new,
he makes a mistake and he gets punished
for it and that's how he's raised.
When he grows up,
he's going to be very reluctant
to try new things in life and, or,
or explore a certain, you know,
aspects of, of creativity,
namely like starting his own business.
That's why most people don't start their
own business because they've lived that
kind of,
I think most of us have lived that kind
of life where if you make a mistake when
you're a kid, you get punished
for it. Even in school,
when you make a mistake on your test,
you get that red x on the thing.
You got five wrong out of 10
you've got a 50% you've got an f,
there's your punishment, your f, oh
wait, I don't know these five things.
Can I learn to all take the test
again and show you that, oh no, no,
you got an APP. There is your
punishment. Repeat the grade.
[inaudible] sucks.
There's your problem.
So you didn't even want to
make any mistakes. You don't
want to try anything new.
You don't want to.
And you just have that mindset.
And that's what most people are like that.
There is however, a point
where people, you know,
you could be raised in a way where you're
not responsible for your own actions
because there's no
consequences to what you do.
So if you don't study and you get the
Red Xs all over your test and you don't
receive any punishment for it,
then you will never learn because
only only he who suffers remembers.
Right?
But there the difference in you this,
I know it always comes back to that
dichotomy that you talk about where it's,
it's really in the middle area.
So
I think that it has to be leaning
towards that what you were saying.
Let them give them freedom to operate.
If you make a mistake,
but they're putting effort into it,
that should be commended. Don't,
if you get one wrong,
too wrong,
don't give them this trophy that says,
Hey, congratulations. You've failed.
A failure should, should be. I mean, the
goal right, is to make successful people.
I will, I will. Despite what I said or in,
in conjunction with what I said about
there needing to be consequences,
I agree that the correct answer or the
correct reaction would not be you failed
your horrible, but you failed.
What did you learn? Yeah.
How can we improve? Yes,
exactly. Exactly right.
So you notice that was exactly, exactly
double. Exactly. Exactly right. Yes,
for sure.
So yeah,
they kind of get the best of both
worlds where they get get that,
that the fact that they failed,
they understand that. And of course,
no one's just like,
no one's goal is to fail.
So they know that they failed.
They understand that they failed,
but encouraged to improve
and encouraged to understand.
But I think in a lot of ways people
don't get that. Yeah. You definitely,
you definitely don't see it when in
businesses you definitely don't see it in
the military. Um, and so yeah, you're
right. You've got to encourage that. Yeah.
And it,
and I think it could get,
and this is just me speaking
from zero experience,
but I would imagine that it would get
really rigid in the military because the
stakes are a lot higher. Well, that's
why this is talking about training. Yeah.
You don't want to let people make
those kinds of mistakes in combat.
You won't give them that much rope where
they can get somebody killed in combat.
Yeah. When, yeah. In a
training in, in, in life,
in a learning situation
or a developing phase,
which in life really is your whole life.
But so always learning, always learning.
So I think to stick to
that, I don't know, format,
whatever you want to call it,
to stick to that where understanding
your mistakes don't like a mistake,
a legitimate mistake.
The punishment should not be the
significant part of that experience.
The learning, the learning should
be, and hey look, I understand this.
Different philosophies.
You know, there's gotta be,
there's gotta be some consequence.
Some people don't learn without consorts.
You see that for these days with these,
some of the new generation,
which your, you might even be a
part of a, but the new, you know,
the new generation that grows up,
consequence for use and they don't take
any responsibility for their actions.
They don't take ownership of anything
that goes wrong because they've been
raised in a way where failure doesn't
matter and there's no consequences to
their actions. Yeah.
So absolutely true. Um,
not to beat a dead horse on this subject.
I had some notes in here around this from
the book trying too hard to follow the
book while solving battlefield situations
makes one fairly predictable even to
enemies who haven't read the book.
These don't you have to make some
changes and back to the book,
these don't have to be drastically
different from what's in the book.
Often it's enough just
to very amount of speed,
stealth or deception with which
the standard method is executed.
Standardizing what subordinates
practice in peace time may make those
subordinates easier to control,
but does not help them learn
the alternative alternative
techniques needed to
develop momentum and battle. So that
actually supports your last statement.
Is it standardizing?
Standardizing what subordinates
practice in peace time may make those
subordinates easier to control.
So if you're trying to control someone
by beating them down and saying,
you failed,
you need to do it this way and this is
the only way you're going to get more
control over them,
but you're going to not allow them to
operate in the real world where they have
to think of new ideas and take out. I
think you'd have to free their mind. Yeah,
and in a way you might,
I would hypothesize,
you might not even get the best out of
them really. I believe you are correct.
We could get that, that rigid standard
of, of output. And that's Kinda it. And,
and going to a quote from
the book supporting your
hypothesis from Colonel Merit
a Edson,
he goes on about how you need to fight
the Japanese and he closes with encourage
your individuals and bring them out,
which is just a beautiful statement.
Now this is, this is kind of to
close out this section here. Um,
we are talking about,
and this,
this definitely applies to life.
Human beings are always
trying to structure the chaos
of battle and that may be
the root of the problem.
Okay.
Human Beings,
human beings want to have structure.
They want things to be orderly and
combat is not orderly nor his life,
nor our relationships, nor
our business deals. Yup.
Nor is the chain of command,
nor our personalities and
Egos and everything that we
try and do to control this
chaos.
The idea that we can control it is false.
Yeah. What you have to do is
you have to deal with it, right?
You have to let that thing
squirm underneath you.
You have to let it move and see where
its weaknesses are and grab hold of what
you can and let go of what you can't. Kind
of like. Um, you know the physio balls?
Yeah. They're kind of,
they're not rigid or nothing.
Why are we talking about when I'm training
with someone that's bigger than me?
You know, you get on top of,
you can't hold them down.
You have to let them move
underneath you. Yeah. Yeah.
And that's what this reminds me of.
Yeah.
I'll add this to your list of
things that aren't controllable.
Um,
all of the existence this way,
like you think of a
leaf or a U. Dot. K Con.
Consider something that's control.
That's why we invent rulers.
That's why we invent thermometers.
You
know, temperature is so
dynamic. I can walk right five
feet away. The temperature,
when you really come down
to the temperature's going
to be different. There's no
set controlled anything.
Everything is so ambiguous and slippery.
And we were saying everything,
everything, all of existence does. But,
but like how you said people
try to control. That's kind.
I think that's in our nature though.
That's what you smell with rulers and
mile markers and it is and it can drive
you crazy. If you try and
control the chaos of combat,
you're going to get destroyed.
And if you try and control
everything in your life,
things that are not controllable
than you're going to destroy it.
If you try and control the relationship
and aspects of relationship that are not
controllable, you know
what? You control them.
The relationship you control you yourself
in a real ambiguous way, by the way,
because you're always adapting.
Ideally from an ideal standpoint,
you're always adapting as well.
So yes, like this kind of Lens,
you know what control you try and control
the relationship by controlling the
other person when reality,
you need to control yourself
because most people don't do that.
[inaudible] most people don't exercise
the beauty of mind control that they can
control your mind.
You can think what you want to think.
You can put those thoughts into your head.
You can eliminate the bad ones.
You can bring forth the good
ones with mind control. Yeah.
And I almost want to close on that because
that's such a good thing to remember,
but I will follow it up with this.
It says complex instructions are at
best premature during what is usually an
inaccurate assessment of the situation.
So when you're looking at something and
you're going, okay, here's the plan,
here's what we're going to do at
best that's premature and inaccurate,
what your plan is.
So when you're trying to figure out what
you're gonna do with that business deal
and you're trying to create this very
detailed plan around it, at best,
it's premature and inaccurate.
At best. It's premature and
accurate. So don't get locked around.
You're gonna make these
plans are going to be rigid.
And here's the way we're going to do
it. At best, it's premature to accurate.
So think about what you can
control and what you can't
and move forward from there.
A good example of recognizing,
or a good way to recognize if you're not
practicing these types of thoughts are,
you know,
ways of looking at things is when you
make a plan and the plan and it doesn't go
according to plan.
And you get mad about it,
your [inaudible] and your red
flag, red flag right there.
That is a red flag. Yeah.
And, and when your relationship isn't
going the way you want it to be,
it's because you should be a newsflash
that you can't control this other human
being. Yeah. You can only
control you. So don't,
and this goes back to what we talked about
on the last show when we talked about,
you know, your family, your close friends
and you know,
we kinda got to the point where
I think I was saying, hey,
you can't worry about them.
Then you said the same thing.
And I think this is a little bit more
clarity on that point is you cannot
control them, right. So you
need to grab what you can,
you know, keep it in, keep it
as under control as you can,
but you're not going to get the
solid control that you went.
Thank you that you desire.
Yeah.
It's kind of like if you have this big
like trashcan lid and then you have this
blob of mercury,
you're trying to keep it in the center
but don't try to like squeeze it with
your hand if something cause it's going
to come out of your fingers, you know?
Yeah.
And,
and that what if your co host of a show
comes up with examples like a trashcan
lid and mercury. You can't control
that. All you can do is listen,
nod your head and say good point.
It's more of a is an analogy, you
know, it's like this comparison of,
you know, using metaphors
check. So moving on,
moving on to some questions that
we've got from Twitter, from Facebook,
got some really good questions.
And as a matter of fact,
these are a continuation of questions
I didn't even ask this time because we
didn't get through many of them from
the last time I asked for input.
So these are a continuation,
which means I apologize once again,
I don't have the names collected of
who gave these questions. So my fault,
I apologize if you,
if we answer your question,
we appreciate you giving us the
question so that we could answer it.
First one,
let's get down to it.
So in regards to Jujitsu,
this is kind of a common question,
but your input, GI or no GI,
do you train both?
It's that job.
The answer is ghee and Nogi.
I definitely train both.
I like to train both.
I don't care which one they're both fond
of me and just as we've been talking
about a lot tonight through the book,
the last hundred yards,
I want my training to be
different and surprising and
be uncontrollable.
And when you change it definitely affects
you when you change from g and then
all of a sudden you take off your game
and you're sliding all over the place,
you have to be a better grappler
to be able to deal with that.
So I want to be a better grappler.
So I do that. And you know there's,
there's something else that's in between
gay Nogi and that's when you put MMA
gloves on,
you put MMA gloves on and it is somewhere
in between g and Nogi because you can
get legitimate risk control.
It's hard to sneak in a choke on
somebody when they're wearing gloves.
So there's, there's benefits to
them all. And I try and do them all.
Yeah.
What
do you find any benefit to doing
one and or the other? You know,
like if you treat it in the g there's
certain benefits and training with a G.
I think if,
if he trained with a g you,
your defense has to be better
because there's more friction.
And so if you're going to
escape an arm lock with the on,
you have to do it very well.
If you're going to escape
a knee lock with the g on,
there's a lot of friction.
It's a lot harder to get out to.
Your defense has to be better with Nogi,
your office has to be better because
there are no handles to grab.
It's slippery that people can slide out
of the exact opposite reasons. So you,
you, I think you improve your
offense more. And I will say this,
my game is compatible with both where I
don't do a lot of crazy lapel weaving in
between your legs then up over your back
and then back over your right arm pit
and around your neck. I don't do a
lot of that. I don't disagree with it.
I think it's fine.
But I like to most of the moves that I do,
um, are compatible with both or there's
very small differences between the way I
have the games set up. Yeah. At the end,
Dean originally told me that same
thing where when you train in the Gi,
your defense starts to develop a little
bit more cause you got to like arm lock,
you're in the arm lock, you can't just
spaz out of an arm lock. It's easy.
And even more important actually is not
the just the submission but across side
or amounts.
What's as a cross side on you with a Gian,
they've got those candles and it's
very difficult to control risk control,
all that stuff. And it's
easier to hold them down. Yeah.
So if you train Nogi and you're
trying to hold some down Nogi,
it actually takes more technique to hold
somebody down with no GI than it does
with Ge. Even though sometimes I hear
people say that g is more technical rep,
I don't actually agree with that.
I think they're both technical
in their own aspect. Yeah. So,
and even in holding someone down, that's
more of an offensive move. Yes. Right.
So if you're being held
down with the ghee,
you got to understand that concept in
those techniques to get out or whether it
be being held down or
submission or whatever.
You have to understand those concepts
and when you understand the concepts,
then you can be successful as
opposed to like a Nogi situation.
You don't necessary, I mean, you
should understand the concept for sure,
but you don't necessarily certainly have
to because you could just spazz out of
it or like an arm lock.
You can, if you're sweaty,
you get spazz out of an arm
lock. We little technique,
you know, if you're strong,
um, with the gets going to be
way harder to do that. So you'll,
you'll kind of in a way learn more and
flip flop when you go on offense to
defense. The same kind of thing
with the Nogi offensive stuff.
You got to understand where you
got to control his shoulder,
otherwise he's gonna, you know,
have enough room to slide it up.
So you have to have that perfect control
to execute a good submission if the
guy's good. So, um, and I
think, you know, with life,
what I do in life is I try and
put myself in tough situations.
So I'm practicing them to him, he used
to them and you know, that's what,
that's what the physical
aspect of life is to do.
In order to improve,
you gotta challenge yourself and put
yourself in the worst scenarios and go and
try and get through them.
You know,
whether that's a weight room with a
squat rack or whether that's a run or
whether that's a swim or whatever
that physical challenges you want to,
you want to make it as difficult as
possible or putting yourself out there or
putting yourself out there.
As I have challenged myself to be
outside my comfort zone into the world of
humans. Multimedia. Yes.
They say,
well I've heard that public speaking
is the number one fear of people.
I have heard that as well. Yeah. And,
and I, it's hard for me to relate to.
I have no, I do, I'm not afraid of
getting up and talking in front of people.
Like he, like he doesn't,
I don't understand that.
I don't understand what that
must feel like. You know?
So you understand why though I,
it's really hard for me to understand.
It's hard for you to relate,
right. Well, cause man, it's,
do you get nervous talking in front
of people? Yeah, yeah. To a degree.
I mean obviously it depends
on the mood, depends on the
people, right. But yeah. Uh,
yeah I think I'm really no different than,
than most people in that regard for sure.
But yeah, there's a reason for that.
I think it's because it's,
it's almost like this subconscious feeling
that everyone's judging every little
thing that comes out of your mouth, every
little thing that you do movement wise,
you know,
so your whole being is being judged by
all kinds of different people with all
the different standards.
Yeah.
And when you care about that or when
you've paid the price for that baby,
I think, cause we, you know, when you get
raised, I think he paid a price for that.
If you say the wrong thing, if
you do the wrong thing. Yeah.
And I think that in a way ridiculed or
you know, whatever, whatever you put,
however that looks for you,
you've paid the price for um,
growing up or [inaudible]
on a large scale. Yeah.
And that's exactly what you got.
You're in a,
in a situation where
that's all kind of coming.
You're coming into your brain where you,
you fear that price that
you're going to pay.
And it's times a thousand because
there's a thousand people there.
And I think it's kind of subconscious
all you're left with consciously is this
just anxiety.
That's how we feel for
your mind. Deco. No,
you've got to put yourself in those bad
situations. Yes to, you know, put your,
if you're gonna public speak or if you're
afraid of public speaking book a small
thing or I don't know, do do something
like put yourself in that situation.
And if you don't want
to go from zero to 10,
do a small one, you know, do something
like with low consequences, know,
are less impactful
consequences and just
start small and go up.
That's probably what you did.
So next question.
Next question.
Um, so okay. Micromanagers how
do you deal with micro managers?
Okay.
So you worked for me and you were super
squared away then I was a great boss and
totally left you alone.
If you worked for me and
you are not squared away,
I was a complete micromanager.
So that's a little indicator.
Now I have worked from
micromanagers before. Everyone does.
You run into them in the world.
And the way,
the best way I've figured to
get out from under the, the,
the,
the draconian thumb of the micromanager
is to try and gain their trust.
And what you want to do is
you want to be ahead of them.
You want to,
and actually this is something that I,
when I was on the Tim Ferriss program,
I talked about how when I told my dad I
was joining the military and I was just
rebellious kind of crazy kid and he said,
oh,
you're going to hate it because you
hate authority. And I did it anyways.
And when I got in I was like,
Damn,
my dad was right. I do hate authority.
I don't like listening to people.
And now I have to listen
to them all the time.
And then I realized very quickly when
I was doing my first seal platoon,
I didn't want anyone
to tell me what to do.
And I was in charge of the radio as
I was a radioman. And what I did,
what I did was, you know, if
the radios had to be ready,
I knew they had to be ready.
I just got them ready.
I got them ready ahead of a time.
I did everything before
anyone could tell me to do it.
I would come into work to be ready
before anyone could tell me what to do.
So I basically was completely
psychotically proactive
and just was ahead of the
power curve on every little thing that
I could be ahead of the power curve on.
And eventually it didn't take long.
The people that micromanaged me,
all of a sudden we're like, Hey, I'm not
going to bother with this guy anymore.
He's already done it. Cause every
time they say, Hey, do you have,
it's already done. Mm. Hey,
did you start preparing their
already did them this morning.
And eventually they say, okay,
this guy knows what he's doing.
And what you're trying to do is build
up the trust. Cause that's what it is.
It's a little,
it's a little,
a lack of trust that people have that
things are going to go the way and they've
probably learned that somewhere.
So don't hold it against him,
but it's your job to create a relationship
with them of trust where they stop
micromanaging you and move on to somebody
else that needs to be micromanaged
next.
Okay. So what about family and uh,
and people who are close to you,
are they all the same? And if
not, how do you deal with it?
So this is the,
the trials and tribulations of the Alpha
personality and you're always trying to
go hard and go fast
and make things happen.
And how do you deal with this as someone
that asking this and whoever you are,
thank you for asking this question.
Okay.
People are people like me. Are they same?
And if not, how do I deal with it? Well,
first of all, no, there's
not too many people like me.
And, and as a matter of fact,
there's not too many people like you
echo and people that are listening this,
there's not too many
people like you either.
People are unique and I'm not trying to
make people like me or make them do the
things that I do. I'm, I'm
over that phase. You know,
I've talked about this before.
Like there was a time where I would try
and convince people about things and I
don't try and do any more, I'll discuss
them, but I'm not here to win an argument.
Um,
I'm not that concerned about you.
I'm not that concerned about
what you think. I'll again, if,
if you're someone that I'm friends with
and I'm trying to help Ya, I'm concerned,
but I'm not trying to
change people's minds. Um,
but it's interesting because what I'm
really trying to do is I'm trying to
appreciate people's perspectives.
I'm trying to learn from other people.
And I thought this was
actually speaking of Twitter.
I'm on Twitter the other day.
I posted a,
a little paragraph and it's by
a gay guy named Mark Rippetoe,
who's a coach. He's written, you
know, probably one of the best,
one of the best books about
weightlifting that you can get.
It's called starting strength, basic
barbell training, mark Rippetoe.
But the opening of it is freaking awesome
and I brought it with me so I could
read it to you. Uh, so
here's, here's this,
this opening to this
book about weightlifting.
Physical strength is the
most important thing in life.
This is true whether we
want it to be or not.
As humanity has developed
throughout history,
physical strength has become less
critical to our daily existence,
but no less important to our lives.
Our strength more than any other thing
we possess still determines the quality
and the quantity of our
time here in these bodies.
Whereas previously our physical strength
determined how much food we ate and how
warm and dry we stayed.
It now merely determines how well we
function in these new surroundings.
We have crafted for ourselves
as our culture has accumulated,
but we are still animals.
Our physical existence
is in the final analysis,
the only one that actually matters.
A weak man is not as happy as the
same man would be if you were strong.
This reality is offensive to some people
who would like the intellectual or
spiritual to take precedence.
It is instructive to see what happens
to these very people as their squat
strength goes up.
Now that's freaking epic,
right?
That is an epic call out to the
passion that coach Rupp until has.
Right? That's just awesome. So I put that
on Twitter. I was fired up, you know,
and cause somebody mentioned starting
strength and I said, yeah, of course,
you know,
this is a classic and a,
some somebody on Twitter,
um,
wrote back and it said,
I disagree.
I will avoid reading things like this.
And I wrote back in again, I'm not
trying to argue with anybody. Um,
I just wrote back, hey, when I don't
agree with people on a subject,
I don't avoid it. I just try
and learn from it. And, and
the fact of the matter is,
even though I think what coach road is
awesome, I actually don't agree with it.
I don't think that strength is
the most important thing in life.
I think knowledge is more powerful.
I think respect and loyalty and
honor and treating people well.
I think all those things are
more important than strength.
And there's been people
that were incredibly weak
in the world that have done
amazing things and we're powerful leaders
and we're incredible human beings.
So I don't actually,
you know,
believe that strength is literally
the most important thing.
Yeah.
Now, that being said,
um, if you are smart,
if you are an intellectual than you
realize that you should use that knowledge
to be strong so you can not be physically
bullied so you can be healthy so you
can protect yourself.
So you can be self reliant.
I mean there's no doubt that strength is
a, is a powerful force. But like I said,
there's many other things that I
think are more important now. But,
but what I like about it is that
hearing this opinion broadens my mind.
It makes me smarter.
It makes me understand how important
strength is to some people.
And maybe that it should be more
important in my head. Because honestly,
when I read that for the first time
years ago, I was like, Oh, you know what?
That's awesome.
And I should always keep somewhere in my
mind that being strong is important and
being strong is good.
And you know,
in this day and age people actually, I
think, believe that being strong is bad.
As crazy as that might sound, there's
nothing wrong with being strong. You know,
being strong is good. Nevermind nothing
wrong. It's a good thing to be strong.
I wish I was stronger.
I try and get stronger and I'm
not a naturally strong person.
I'm just kind of an average
person that works out a lot.
So
my point there is a number number one,
when you get people that are
different than you don't try.
I don't try and change them.
I try and keep an open mind.
I try and learn from them.
Okay,
I'm trying,
and I talked about this earlier tonight,
people have strengths and people have
weaknesses and if people have strengths,
I'm going to try and learn from
their strengths and some people are,
I have more weaknesses and I
try and learn from them as well.
You get someone that's an addict,
you get someone that's of a social
path or you get someone that's a,
you know, a, a real giver
or someone that helps them.
There's people that one thing that I
don't feel like I help people enough.
Um, and so I always look at people
that are very helpful and I say, okay,
what can I do? What can I take away
from their perspective? But you know,
if I meet someone that's an addict,
I learned from them.
They teach me very important lessons,
people that are winners,
people that are losers.
I'm going to learn from both of them.
Now back to the original question
of how do you deal with it,
eight, because I'm, I'm,
I'm inferring from the question that
this person that asked it gets frustrated
that others are not living up
to their expectations. Now,
this is going to sound bad
when I say this initially
is that
I actually have relatively,
or I shouldn't say I have,
I keep relatively low
expectations of humans.
Meaning when I meet someone,
I don't expect to get a lot out of them.
I expect to be let down. I expect
people, as I talked about the other day,
people are crazy and,
and I expect that.
I expect people to do irrational things.
So that's kind of my baseline.
And then what's beautiful about
it is I'm surprised and happy and
in
sh t pleasantly surprised
when people are supportive,
when people are reliable, when people
are good people, when they make sense,
when they're not crazy.
And so I think setting the right level
of expectations is important to keep
yourself from going crazy,
trying to change people.
The other thing I like about this attitude
is
I'm not sitting there blaming
on other people around me.
I'm not blaming whether it's my family,
whether it's my team,
whether it's my people I work with.
I'm not blaming them for being unmotivated
or blaming them for not trying hard
or blaming them for whatever.
I'm just taking responsibility for
what's happening in my, for me,
I'm taking responsibility.
If they're not motivated,
I need to try and motivate
me if I care about them,
if they're dragging
me down, whose fault is
that? That's not their fault.
I'm letting them drag me down.
So I'm taking responsibility
of my interactions with
people to make sure I move
it in the right direction.
And as a leader,
it's my job to get the most out of people.
I mean,
I always talked about
that you're going to have,
your whole team is not going to be studs.
You're going to have people on your team
that are weak and it's your job to get
what you can out of that person.
Take advantage of whatever
strengths they might have,
cover for the weaknesses where you can,
that's what you're doing as
a leader and you're leading,
whether that's leading in business or
your team or your group of friends or
whatever.
You're taking a leadership position
and you're getting what you can out of
people.
And that's how I deal with
people that are close to me
that are not the same as me.
Don't want to hang around with a bunch
Booyah I don't mind hanging around people
that are like me.
Seal teams is pretty,
the seal teams has a lot of
people with the similar, you know,
they're like got some similar
personalities in there,
which is always fun
too. Yeah, for sure. Um,
are there, so you say you
have, um, low expectations.
Is there, isn't that sound
bad? I apologize to people
of the world right now. Yeah.
That when I look at you, I
have low expectations and
don't think of it that way.
Yeah.
I'm seeing in my own mind,
I'm just setting low expectations because
don't expect a lot, you know? Yes.
That's,
I expect shittiness you expect,
you just don't expect, I just thought,
yes. Yeah. So if someone's making this,
you know,
tall claim,
you don't expect that claim
to be fulfilled 100% or you
know, or whatever I sent,
I set low expectations and I look to be
pleasantly surprised by those people in
the world. The people that are listening
to this podcast, you all out there,
you're going to, you know, fire
me up, you know? Um, but, but,
but really that's, you know, most
people that you meet you can't rely on.
Right.
And that's why it's important to find
people that are likeminded and link arms
with them and go forward into the fray.
Yeah.
And it's not like people
are unreliable specifically.
It's just that if you set your own
specific expectations on people because
everyone's different, you're
different. Like are you saying,
so if you set your specific expectations,
which I think most of us do
that in one way or another,
we expect certain things all the way down
to the language. We use. Some people,
you know, some people don't like if they
are called boss, you know, you're like,
hey boss, it's a bus
someday. I'm gonna be honest.
I don't really like that when
someone calls me boss, you know,
if you don't know your name, you
know, hey bro, same thing boss.
But they meant it in a good way,
you know? But I expect, yeah,
I expect you never to use that word when
you address me kind of thing. Got It.
It's not that serious. But
anyway, that's just a small guy.
So if you start setting
your own expectations,
your specific own
expectations, consciously and
subconsciously, yeah, you, you,
you'll probably get let down. Guess what,
whose fault is that? It's your fault.
And you know, it's a good,
good time to this is,
and I run in this with business leaders
where they know they're super over
achievers and they expect that level
of performance out of everyone.
And they're not going to get it. And the
way I explain it to them, I say, listen,
I understand what you want to have happen.
But just because as a leader,
the lead, the platoon commander is
able to carry a hundred pound rucksack,
10 kilometers into the target,
hit the target and walk back
out another 10 kilometers.
Doesn't mean that everybody
else in the platoon can do it.
And therefore he cannot plan that mission.
Right.
And I would usually get Fruto him on that
because they do realize that there are
high performers and that they're over
achievers and that they're not going to
get. So how are you going to set
the expectations so that you're,
you've got people that can act actually
achieve the expectations you've set for
them. So that's right on point, boss.
Sorry. Yes, I did get men and set
those look kind of low expectations.
I know that sounds about them, be them,
but let them be there. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And that way when you get less,
if you get let down,
actually you probably have a
less chance of getting let down.
So it's essentially you're minimizing
the downside, maximizing the upside.
That's a pause. Your relationship,
very positive way of putting it. Yes,
you are correct.
Thank you for making me give him a
positive spin to my negative attitude.
Yeah, I think I understand
what you mean. I think so
part of it is denial by the way,
because I don't want in every admit or
think that you had low expectations of me
and my functionality.
MMM.
Okay. We'll go next question.
Uh, okay. What are the top three,
the top three to 10 business
problems you're asked to solve?
Good question.
Interesting question because why would
you say top three to 10 who wrote that?
That's crazy. You know, you'd say
three or four or three to five maybe,
but three to 10 on, no, this is
actually should be top three. We'll,
we'll go for it. That being
said, here's the problem.
Here's the problem that we come up against
in life and I deal with on a regular
basis is we get called in due to either
a lack of execution or desire to improve
execution.
And this is the same thing we dealt with,
with working with leadership
in the seal teams.
You get teams that are not
executing correctly. That's,
that's the problem that
we come in to solve.
Now that execution could be production,
that execution could be sales,
that execution could be manufacturing,
it could be anything that execution.
So
that's what we always get asked to solve.
That being said,
why is there a problem and
execution and the problems,
these are where you get like the,
okay,
five to seven kind of common problems
that we deal with. We address,
we address most of, most
of them, uh, own fact,
we address all the major ones in the book.
There's a few nuanced ones,
but uh, you know, the, generally
the issues are like, oh,
you can't get people to buy in.
We always hear that our folks aren't
buying in buying into the plan,
the philosophy, your
strategy, whatever. Uh, do,
people don't understand what's happening.
They don't,
they don't understand the vision.
And we'd go back and we say, okay,
do they understand the why or are they,
is, how was the vision being communicated?
How is the vision being translated
up and down the chain of command?
Because you go down from the CEO who has
a vision and the way he would speak to
that vision is a lot different
than the way a front line,
you know, equipment operator is going
to want to understand that vision.
So is the strategy simple
and understandable through
the chain of command that
can cause a lack of execution?
Are there silos?
Are there different elements within the
company that are not helping each other
and supporting each other
with a good cover and move?
Is there micromanagement going on?
We were talking about micromanagement.
Micromanagement can cause
legitimate problems of execution.
Is there unclear guidance
that can cause problems?
Is there ego interfering that can cause
problem is their ego driving process
instead of
the best methodology driving process.
Sometimes it's ego driving process.
So it's all these and there's just these
problems and there we've seen them all.
I don't think I've seen a new problem yet
in quite some time where I've said, oh,
I've never seen this before and we,
we,
and there are always these
problems of execution.
Are leadership problems and we've seen
the same thing in some way in the seal
teams. So I think that's
why we've been successful.
It's a company going in and getting people
to execute better because we've seen
it, we know how to fix it, and that's
what we do when. All right. Um,
next question is
how do you handle a buff that doesn't
know as much as you and they don't
understand what you do,
but they're bossy
but they bossy. Okay, so this
is actually a normal situation.
This is not abnormal.
Bosses often don't know as
much as the frontline troops.
I can tell you right now,
I was the boss of 35 or 40 seals when
I was a task and you commander and I
didn't know as much as
they knew about their jobs.
I didn't know what the
snipers knew about sniping.
I didn't know everything that the
radio about knew about the radios.
I didn't know like Lafe Lafe was
working with the Iraqis every,
I didn't know about his Iraqi
soldiers and what they were like.
I couldn't pretend to know that stuff,
but I was actually secure in that fact.
I was okay with that.
And that's what I recognized,
that that wasn't my job
and I was okay with it.
So the question is how do you
deal with someone like that? Well,
let's first recognize the fact that
they are insecure in their job.
So the reason I was able to like let my
guys run stuff just cause I was secure
with myself as a leader.
And then my position,
when you're dealing with
someone that's still bossy,
they're trying to impose
upon you how to do things.
And that is because the
root of that is likely,
I don't want to call it
out as a hundred percent,
but the root of that
is likely in security.
He's insecure about his authority,
insecurity about his leadership,
insecure about his position.
So when you want to deal with it,
how do you deal with it?
Your job becomes in this situation to
make your boss feel secure in their
position. That's what your goal
becomes. That means an end. Yes.
You know what that means? It
means nodding your head. And,
and giving them credit where
they might not deserve it
and inflating their ego,
or not inflating,
but massaging their ego a little bit.
And you know what that means?
The hardest part of that isn't massage.
And there you go.
The hardest part of is
checking your own ego.
The hardest part of that is saying is,
is you want to prove to them
that you know more than they do,
and that just bubbles up and over and it
will ruin your relationship and it will
ruin the,
the job that you're trying to do of make
them feel secure because you're like,
hey boss, actually you're wrong.
It's this. Well, your ego feels good,
but guess what? You just hurt his
ego. Now is what they're going to do.
They're going to try and
pose more will upon you.
So you've actually gone backwards.
You win the battle, you lose the war.
So what you need to do is
make that boss feel secure,
massage their ego.
Don't try and prove that you know more.
Try and prove that you're
there to support and help.
And in the long run that will be
the beneficial way to improve that
relationship. Let them recognize or
let them feel secure with what they at,
where they're at and
then they won't impose,
try and impose their will on you as
the boss man yet that I'm going to add,
uh, let you kind of what you were
saying I think last time. Um,
it's a small, tiny side note but I think
it's really important when you try,
when you're doing that,
when you're or, or making
them feel more secure as a boss.
Um,
be sure to come off
genuine and consistent.
Remember how we were talking about that?
Because a lot of people they'll be like,
okay,
that's what I'm going to do.
And then they overtly want to show
that that's what they're doing,
whether it be to other people because
you know, maybe they got scolded or,
or whatever in front of other people
and then so they overtly do it and it
doesn't come off as genuine
than it's counterproductive.
Yes. This is called, well, this is
what I used to call in the seal teams,
classic over correction and
classical over correction. You know,
we'd see guys go too far in one direction
because we're always talking about the
dichotomy of leadership. And I'd
say to a guy, oh, you're doing, uh,
you're doing too much. You're not
doing enough decentralized command.
And they do classic overcorrection and
they would lose control of everything.
Or they,
if we told them everyone was too wild
and they didn't have control of anything,
they'd go into level nine micromanagement,
you know,
and just lock everyone down.
So yeah,
you don't want to do a classic
overcorrection. You want to,
you want to moderate and modulate your
efforts to make the person feel secure,
no doubt about it.
Can you apply
extreme ownership at mid level
management versus the C suite level?
Well, this is, this is
absolutely true. Um,
can you apply extreme ownership or the,
the,
the leadership principles that we
talk about in extreme ownership,
can you apply them at mid level management
versus the executive level of the C
suite folks? And the answer's
absolutely yes. And not only that,
but extreme ownership applies
through the entire chain of command.
The principles are meant for everyone
inside the chain of command because as we
talk about all the time, the leadership
just doesn't mean the actual,
um,
designated leaders.
Every person on a team
needs to be a leader.
And while that may sound Cliche,
it is actually true.
So
he,
not only that, but the, the
senior executives at a company,
the CEO that they work for, somebody,
they, whether they work for a board,
uh, whether it's, you know,
Steve jobs in charge of apple,
guess what he's reporting to shareholders.
So everyone has some kind of boss.
Everyone's working for
somebody and everybody needs
to use these principles all
the way up and down the chain of command.
The principles of leadership don't change
no matter where you are in the chain
of command or what situation you're in.
And that's why, you know, we're getting,
we get called in to help every level of
the chain of command from the frontline
troops, from literally from the frontline
troops, the the equipment operators,
the operators in the field,
the salespeople on the front lines.
We work with them all the way
up to the CSUITE and above.
Yeah.
Just like how you're thinking applies
to everybody and in every situation it's
up. It's absolutely true. Like in life,
in a relationship with your husband
or wife and in the relationship
with your kids. Same exact thing. Yeah.
Like if you're taking responsibility
for everything you did wrong and right.
Right. I would imagine you
take responsibility for
the right things he did,
but if you're taking responsibility,
I think that's when you can
eventually function the way that,
that you hope that you'll be able
to function. You are correct.
Just to be clear though,
when you do do something right and
you are in a leadership position,
you actually don't take
responsibility for it. You push that,
you push that praise of
accomplishment to the team. Aw,
yeah, yeah, yeah. You never want to
absorb that. That's advanced, Bro.
That's actually white belt material.
Last question I think. Um,
how do you deal with setbacks,
failures,
delays,
defeat or other disasters?
How do I deal with
setbacks, failures, delays,
defeat or other disasters?
I actually have a
fairly simple way of dealing with these
situations and is actually one word to
deal with all those situations.
And that is good.
And this is actually something
that one of my direct subordinates,
one of my guys that worked for me
pointed out to me and he would,
he would call me up or pull me
aside with some major problems,
some issue that was going on and he'd say,
possibly got this and that and the other
thing. And I look at him and I'd say,
good.
And finally one day he was telling me
about some issue that he was having some
problem and he said, I already know
what you're going to say. And I said,
well, what am I going to say? You said
you're going to say good. He said,
that's what you always say when
something is wrong in going bad.
You always just look at me and
say, good. And I said, well yeah,
and,
and I mean it and that is how I
feel when things are going bad,
there's going to be some good
that's going to come from it and oh,
mission got canceled. Good. We can
focus, focus on another one. Um,
didn't get the new high speed gear. We
wanted. Good. We can keep it simple.
Didn't get promoted good.
More time to get better.
Didn't get funded good.
We own more of the company.
Didn't get the job you wanted.
Good.
You can get more experience and
build a better resume. Got Injured.
I got injured. Sprained my ankle. Good.
I needed a break from training.
Got tapped out.
Good. It's better to tap and training
than a tap out on the street.
Got Beat. Good. You learned
unexpected problems.
Good.
We have the opportunity
to figure out a solution.
That's it. That's it.
When things are going bad,
don't get all bummed out. Don't get
startled. Don't get frustrated. No,
you just look at the
issue and you say good.
And I don't mean to say something that's
all cliche and I don't mean to sound
like Mr. Positive. Find a positive,
but do that. Focus on the good.
Take that issue, take that problem
and make it something good.
It'll bring that attitude to
your team too. You go forward.
And lastly,
like to close this out,
if you can say the word good,
guess what it means you're still alive.
It means you're still breathing.
And if you're still breathing,
well the now you still got
some fight left in you.
So get up, dust off, reload,
recalibrate,
reengage,
and go out on the attack.
And that right there is
about as good as it gets.
That's all I got for today.
So everyone that's been listening,
thank you for your patience.
Thanks for listening.
Thanks for spreading the word and most
of all to everyone listening to the Jocko
podcast.
Thank you for getting after it.